Hello, I am Machine Dazzle,
and I am an emotionally-driven,
instinct-based conceptual artist,
designer and musician.
Today I'm going to talk about
the power of transformation
through the sacred ritual of costume.
With the help of my friend Matty Crosland.
Matty?
Oh, hey, girl.
(Laughs)
Matty is going to hand out a few seeds
of possibility while I continue.
Growing up in Middle America,
I wasn't allowed to be who I was.
I was discouraged
from a career in the arts.
When we went to the toy store,
my two brothers would run
to the black and blue aisle
and I would run to the pink aisle.
There was a lot of shame
surrounding my preference
for "girls'" toys.
I shoplifted my first Barbie.
Desperate people do desperate things.
But what was really happening
during that time
is I was building up
a massive reserve of ideas,
unrealized desires and dreams.
And when I bought
that one-way ticket to New York,
which is the first decision
I ever truly made for myself,
I brought with me that reserve
of unrealized dreams, desires and ideas.
And that's when I really
started to take risks.
And I learned about the power
of transformation,
starting with becoming my true self.
In 2019, I was commissioned by Guggenheim
Works and Process to do a show.
I knew immediately that I wanted to make
a show about my mother, Deborah.
Here she is, printed on my dress.
It was the '60s, the bouffant,
the cat-eye frames.
Maybe some of you remember.
Sadly, I lost my mother in 1996 to cancer.
So in her honor, I created
a rock and roll cabaret.
It features songs that I wrote
and sang about her,
my relationship with her
and my self-actualization.
It is called "Treasure,"
and you can listen to it
on your favorite streaming service.
In fact, I just released
the first dance track from it.
It's called "Understand,"
and if you like to wiggle your peach,
then you should look it up.
(Laughter)
My opening outfit,
I created this big '60s bouffant.
It is made out of about 2,500
metallic pipe cleaners.
Why pipe cleaners?
Because wigs are common.
And I like to challenge existing systems
and take risks.
And it is actually quite heavy.
Transformation takes commitment.
Did I mention that my work is maximal?
We are complex beings.
We exist in many layers.
Speaking of layers,
then I added this swing coat.
It's made out of an old American flag
camouflaged in paint, dye
and adorned with flowers.
Flowers that I found
in the dumpster at the cemetery
where my mother's ashes are buried.
Yes, people take fake flowers
off of the graves,
throw them into the dumpster
to put new fake flowers on the graves.
I thought it was appropriate.
And so there it is,
a source of protection.
On stage, I became not my mother,
that wasn't the point.
I became a higher version of myself.
Not man, not woman.
Something other.
In this show,
I'm hoping to realize all
of my dreams and not just mine,
but all of my mother's, too,
because she had them.
More is more.
One of my -- yes, I wish
you could all have them,
but you know how it is.
(Laughter)
Pom pom on head, look at that.
One of my most maximal projects to date
is with my favorite collaborator,
Taylor Mac.
Together with hundreds of others,
we created a 24-hour show.
It is called "24 Decades:
A History of Popular Music."
It premiered in Brooklyn
at St. Ann’s Warehouse in 2016.
It's a 24-hour show.
It starts in 1776 and goes
to the present day.
Every hour of the show is dedicated
to a different decade in American history.
For every decade, I created a costume
that is conceptually adjacent,
not historically accurate.
Why?
Because traditional historical
costume already exists,
conceptually and otherwise.
And I like to break traditions
and invent new ones.
And when you break an egg,
there are countless ways to turn it
into something delicious.
So it’s high noon in Brooklyn
at St. Ann’s Warehouse.
It's the top of the show in 1776,
right after we freed ourselves
from the British in the United States.
And inspiration came when I was walking
in Brooklyn, where I live.
I was passing this laundromat.
What were they doing?
They were taking down these old,
plastic, grand-opening flags.
What were they doing?
They were putting up new plastic,
grand-opening flags.
Well, I snatched them out
of the garbage because, you know,
and I noticed how weather-worn
and brittle and fragile they were.
And I got to thinking about the end
of the American Revolution
and how tattered
and torn and broken
everything must have been.
And then it hit me.
This costume wants to tell a story.
An illegitimate child of colonialism
ran away from home to New Orleans
and opened the laundromat
called Lou Washery,
and they are celebrating
the Grand Overture as the official,
unofficial cheerleader
of the original 13 colonies.
This is maximalism.
Not only is it layer
upon layer aesthetically,
it's idea on top of idea conceptually.
It becomes its own story, almost
that you can almost read like a book.
Well, if history has taught us anything,
it's that things change.
Here we are an hour later in the show,
and it's time for a costume change.
An apple pie as a headdress.
The care and the craft
and the smell of home.
And I put two pipes on Taylor's back,
upholstered in a colonial fabric,
steam was coming out of them
at the top of that decade.
But you know how it is.
And they represent the invention
of the steam engine,
which gave way to westward expansion,
for better or for worse.
And then I thought, well,
what else was happening?
Well, George Washington
was president at the time,
and I was always kind of into his little
cherry tree story of virtue.
You know, "I cannot tell a lie,
I chopped down that cherry tree."
And it was the French Revolution
across the pond
and the guillotine was like, full on.
So I was like, "Well, why don't
I combine them together?"
And, oh, you know, severed heads
in cherry tree drag as garment.
What I'm getting at is, the costume
can be so much more than the costume.
It can be the props, it can be the set,
it can tell its own stories,
it can even be its own character.
It can be all of it at the same time.
This kind of maximalism
leaves an audience completely satisfied,
yet wanting more at the same time.
More is more.
Well, wouldn’t you know,
now it’s 7pm at night,
and it's time for the Civil War.
I took two distinct inventions
from this time to help tell this story.
I read somewhere once
that the American hot dog
evolved out of German immigrants
selling their bratwurst and rolls
on the streets during the 1860s.
Well, I like that.
And then this distinctive barbed wire,
you know, barbed wire,
a symbol of separation,
security, insecurity.
Well, I wanted to combine
the two together.
In this way of making things,
I bring order to disorder.
By turning barbed wire into hot dogs,
what I'm trying to do, hopefully,
is eat through what is separating us,
in this case, slavery.
When you believe in something
that is marginalized
and goes against
the mainstream of society,
it is so important that you do it big,
bold, brave and unapologetically,
truly.
OK, well, here we are after the war again.
It’s time for Reconstruction.
And, you know, how about
the invention of the typewriter?
I love the way this piece wiggles
as Taylor clicks across the stage.
And then the introduction of dynamite
and toilet paper on rolls,
how domestic!
Well, I took those empty
toilet paper rolls,
and I painted them to look like sticks
of dynamite and boom --
headdress, hello.
You know, why not?
Well, here we are.
Now, we've been performing all night.
We're tired.
It’s 10am.
It's the 1980s.
Just in time for the AIDS pandemic.
Taylor wears two white, high-heeled shoes
sprinkled with little green pom poms.
They look like clown shoes,
but they represent the white blood cells
being attacked by HIV.
This collaboration, this "24-Decade
History of Popular Music,"
took maximalism and "more is more"
to a whole new level.
I have to say,
through the music, the storytelling
and the transformative
nature of the costumes,
we changed the course of queer history.
And if nothing else,
it sure is fun to pull an all-nighter
with 24 costume changes.
Well, here we are.
This is an image of me
on the streets of New York City
at the Easter Bonnet Parade
several years ago.
I am a fan of taking
my art to the streets.
But I have to tell you,
it takes a little bit of courage
to dress like this in public,
particularly these days.
Just about every part of my creative
ethos is under attack
in the United States right now.
On first glance, you might see
an over-the-top outfit
on a Sunday, in black and white and pink.
But upon closer inspection,
you'll see the details,
the skull peeking out,
the skeletal hand creeping out
of the innocent plush animals on my head.
I once had my Easter bonnet
ripped right off of my head
in front of St. Patrick's Cathedral.
Not this one.
I don't think they would dare.
Sometimes, I think
that life is about overcoming
all of your greatest fears.
Life itself is how you go about that.
I go all the way.
I do the work.
There is no happiness that I know
unless I am risking something.
The only true happiness that I know
comes from this sense of accomplishment,
by taking the risk.
Well, here I am again
on the streets of New York,
this time for the Reclaim Pride
March back in 2019 again.
A good friend gave me
really good advice once.
"Machine,
it's never too early
to be pre-revolutionary,
and it's never too late
to be post-apocalyptic chic."
(Laughter)
Sometimes this course of action,
this transformation, is the most honest
action that you can take.
You owe yourself honesty.
I consider it a prayer.
Today, after all, is a placeholder
for what's coming tomorrow.
By becoming other, you avoid labels.
You can change someone's life
just by walking across the room
because you are changing
what is possible in their minds.
Be more.
You will get more out of life.
And not just for you,
for everyone around you.
I'm telling you,
that is the Gospel truth.
Another thing I wanted to say,
this collective land of make-believe
that we are in right now,
this is very fertile,
very creative space
where anything is possible.
Matty, let's bring it home.
(Music: "Miss Object of Desire"
by Machine Dazzle)
Mother, I want to be
Miss Object of Desire
A walking dream, a Phoenix lips of fire
Strange reflection in the perfumed air
Changing faces till she settles where
a memory vibrates
Liberation
(Applause)
(Music continues) Broken glass
and my dress is torn
Screaming in silence
Thank you.
(Laughs)
(Music continues)
(Applause)
Mother, I want to be Miss Object of desire
A walking dream, a Phoenix lips of fire